Where does the information and dreams come from?
And I think what the w w where it comes from is that we watch the patterns that
everyone acts out.
We've watched that forever and we've got some representations of those patterns.
That's part of our cultural history.
That's what's embedded in stories,
in fictional accounts of,
of the story between good and evil,
the bad guy and the good guy and the romance,
you know,
these are,
these are canonical patterns of being for people in and they deeply affect us
because they represent what it is that we will act out in the world.
And then we fleshed that out with the individual information we have about
ourselves and other people.
And so it's like there's a,
there's a,
there's waves of a behavioral patterns that manifest themselves in the crowd
across time that great dramas are played on the crowd across time.
And the artists watched that and,
and they get intimations of what that is and they write it down and they tell us
and then we're a little clearer about what we're up to.
No.
Like a great dramatists like Shakespeare let's say is we know that what he wrote
is fiction and then we say,
well fiction isn't true.
But then you think,
well wait a minute.
Maybe it's true.
Like numbers are true.
You know,
numbers are an abstraction from the underlying reality,
but no one in their right mind would really think numbers aren't true.
You could even make a case that the numbers are more real than the things that
they represent,
right?
Cause the obstruction is so insanely powerful.
Once you have mathematics,
you're just deadly.
You can move the world with mathematics.
And so it's not obvious that the abstraction is less real than the,
than the,
than the more concrete reality.
And you take a work of fiction like hamlet and you think,
well is that it's,
it's not true because it's fiction.
But then you think,
wait a minute,
what kind of explanation is that?
Like maybe it's more true than nonfiction because it takes what the story that
needs to be told about you and the story that needs to be told about you and you
and you and you and abstracts that out.
And says,
look,
here's something that's a key part of the human experience as such,
right,
so it's,
it's an abstraction from this underlying noisy substrate and people are affected
by it because they see that the thing that's represented as part of the pattern
of their being,
that's the right way to think about it.
And then with these old stories,
these ancient stories,
it seems to me like that process has been occurring for thousands of years.
It's like we watched ourselves and we extracted out some stories,
we imitated each other and we represented that in drama and then we distilled
the drama and we got a representation of the distillation and then we did it
again at the end of that process that took God only knows how long.
I think some of these stories,
they've traced fairytales back 10,000 years,
some fairy tales in relatively unchanged for him.
And it certainly seems to me that the archeological evidence for example,
suggests that the really old stories that that,
that the Bible begins with our,
at least that old and likely embedded in a prehistory that's far older than
that.
And you might think,
well,
how can you be so sure?
The answer to that in part is that cultures that don't change,
like the ancient cultures,
right?
They didn't change as fast as they stayed the same.
That's the answer.
So they call it,
they keep their information moving generation to generation.
That's how they stay the same.
And so we know,
again in the archaeological record,
there are records of rituals that have remained relatively unbroken for up to
20,000 years.
It was discovered in caves in Japan that were set up for a particular kind of
bare worship that was also characteristic of western Europe.
So these things can last for very long periods of time.
We're watching each other act in the world.
And then the question is,
well,
how long have we been watching each other?
And the answered that in some senses,
while as long as there's been creatures with nervous systems and that's a long
time,
you know,
that's some hundreds of millions of years,
perhaps longer than that.
We'd been watching each other trying to figure out what we're up to across that
entire span of time.
Some of that knowledge is built right into our bodies,
which is why we can dance with each other,
for example.
Right?
Because understanding isn't just something that you,
that you have as an abstraction.
It's something that you act out.
You know,
that's what children are doing when they're learning to rough and tumble plays.
They're learning to integrate their body with the body of someone else in a
harmonious way,
learning to cooperate and compete,
and that's all instantiated right into their body.
It's not abstract knowledge.
They don't know that they're doing that.
They're just doing it.
And so we can even use our body as a representational platform.
So we've been studying each other for a long time.
Abstracting out what is it that we're up to and that's that.
That's what is it we're up to,
what should we be up to?
That's even a more fundamental question.
If you're going to live in the world and you're going to do it properly,
what does properly mean and how is it that you might go about that?
Well,
it's the right question,
right?
It's what everyone wants to know.
How do you live in the world?
Not what is the world made of.
It's not the same question.
How do you live in the world?
It's the eternal question of human beings and I guess we're the only species
that has ever really asked that question because all the other animals,
they just go and do whatever they do,
not us.
It's a question for us.
We've had to,
we have to become aware of it.
We have to be able to speak it.
God only knows why,
but that seems to be the situation.
So
we act that acting is shaped by the world,
that acting is shaped by society into something that we don't understand,
but that we can model that.
We can model it.
We model it in our stories,
we Marlett with our bodies and that's where the dream gets its information.
The dream is part of the process that's watching everything and then trying to
formulate it and trying to say,
well,
trying to get the signal from the noise and to portrayed in dramatic form
because the dream is little drama.
And then you get the chairs to s park about what that dream is and then you have
it.
You have something like articulated knowledge at that point.
And so the Bible I would say is,
is it sort of,
it exists in that space that's half into the dream and half into articulated
knowledge.
It's something like that.
And going into it to find out what the stories are about Ken,
what can it can aid our self understanding.
And then the other issue is,
is that if nene,
she was correct and if Dostoevsky or young was correct and Dostoevsky as well
without the cornerstone that that understanding provides,
we're lost.
And that's not good because then we're susceptible to psych pathology.
That's psychological pathology.
You know,
the people who are ad adamant,
anti religious thinkers seem to believe that if we abandoned our immersement in
the underlying dream,
that we'd all instantly become rationalists like Descartes or bacon or you know,
intelligent,
clear thinking,
rational scientific people.
I don't believe that for a moment because I don't think there's any evidence for
it.
I think we would become so irrational so rapidly that the weirdest mysteries of
Catholicism would see positively rational by contrast,
and I think that's already happening.